welome back to on sens Hamas says the
death toll in Gaza has now surpassed
20,000 people with nearly 2 million
others displaced from their often
destroyed homes or calls for permanent
ceasefire are growing ever louder in a
defiant speech today Benjamin Netanyahu
said Israel will not
stop
well should the US now back calls for a
Ceasar and could Israel face sanctions
for the scale of its response October
the 7th join discussed this is the
independent presidential candidate Dr
Corell West and international law expert
Eugene korovich welcome to both of you
um Corno West great to have you back on
the program let me ask you first of all
uh Benjamin Netanyahu tonight very
unequivocal Israel will keep fighting
Hamas until they are
eradicated um which means means it's
going to be months and months more of
what we've been seeing uh what is your
response to
that well as you know I've called for
Netanyahu and IDF to be brought before
the ICC the international criminal court
article 67 and8 crime of genocide crime
against humanity and War crime and what
I mean by that is we need to live in a
world in which we fundamentally believe
that Palestinian suffering has the same
value as Jewish suffering Jewish
suffering has the same value as
Palestinian suffering If This Were A
Palestinian occupation and domination
the Palestinian genocide against Jews in
which there were nearly 8,000 precious
Jewish babies killed in 50 days we'd
have a qualitatively different
discussion qualitatively different
response and I believe Biden Harris
Austin we can go right down the line
Kirby blinkin they are complicities with
Israel's war crimes against the
Palestinians has Hamas committed war
crimes crimes absolutely they've
committed war crimes but not crimes of
genocide and when Nathan yahu invokes
amalak Sam 1st Samuel 15 and3 in the
biblical text and I speak as a Christian
I know the difference between those
Divine sanctioned genocidal commands
kill every woman kill every child in
order to procure our end he's invoked a
number of times October 28th he's
invoked amock that's genocidal intent
and it's genocidal attack flowing from
that intent we have to have a moral
consistency across the board every baby
no matter who they world have the same
value let me go to Eugene then if your
response to that I mean that you'll be
aware Eugene that much of the world is
now watching with horror the scale of
Israel's response and when they hear
Netanyahu saying this isn't going to
stop until we've got rid of all of Hamas
and at best estimates they've only
killed 6 to 7,000 Hamas terrorists and
that's just if you take IDs word for it
that means that 80% of Hamas has not
been eliminated yet how many civilians
are going to get killed in the next few
months or even years before Hamas is
eradicated and how in the end does that
help either peace in the region or how
does it stop just massive escalation and
radicalization against
Israel so how many civilians will die as
largely a function of hamas's decisions
because Hamas has a specific strategy of
trying to kill as many Israeli civilians
as they can as they did on October 7th
and trying to get as many of their own
civilians killed which they do by hiding
in tunnels under populated areas basing
themselves in schools in hospitals their
strategy is to roll up their civilian
death tour which at the same time uh
Israel does everything to limit Israel
is only targeting Hamas now Hamas makes
it difficult by hiding among civilians
and the deaths of those civilians are
Hamas war crimes the accusations of
genocide it's what psychologists call
projection accusing your enemy the other
side of exactly what you're doing to
distract and whitewash what you're doing
October 7th was a genocidal invasion of
Israel where Hamas invaded Israel
chopped up families in front of each
other burned people alive and now Israel
is responding more moderately than any
country casualties let put you on that
in terms of its supposed moderate
response in the last few days alone
we've seen the IDF shoot dead three
Israeli hostages who were wearing no
shirts and had a banner asking for help
they were suren they were surrendering
whoever they were they turned out to be
hostages then we had two women uh
innocent women stand standing outside a
Catholic Church who were also gunned
down by IDF snipers in an action that
the pope called terrorism uh you've also
got President Biden describing the
bombing campaign as indiscriminate which
in itself that description implies a war
crime so this idea that that Israel is
being moderate in its response I don't
think is borne out by reality is
it uh President Biden has actually said
and other American officials have said
that Israel is acting more morally than
any other Army now show me a war without
inadvertent civilian casualties when
America cleared Isis out of mosul 10,000
civilians were killed in that city alone
and America was not fighting an enemy
next door that was actively shooting
rockets at it and holding its citizens
hostage if Professor West had his way
Nazi Germany would still rule Europe
because of course hundreds of thousands
of German civilians died in the war
against Nazi German let me bring
Confederacy would St real half let bring
okay let me hold on about let me just
say about the hostages about the
hostages because that's a sensitive
Point uh that's a tragic incident of
course and we could we we saw today that
the mother of one of the hostages said
she does not blame the Israeli soldiers
she Embraces them because she knows that
Hamas again is responsible for their
deaths because Hamas has used every kind
of subri to trap Israeli soldiers fake
surrenders suicide let me bring back in
Corell West Corell West the moral uh
conundrum here for many people is that
what happened October the 7th was
utterly horrific an appalling terrorist
attack on mostly absolutely civilian
innoc precious he a precious human
beings here's my question here's my
question when you have Hamas
stating since October the 7th we want to
do that again and again and again when
it is their mission statement to wipe
out Israel and any Jews who live in
Israel when when we all can see and hear
them say this with Brazen impunity what
is Israel supposed to do other than
trying to remove
Hamas Hamas is very much like the Jewish
ergon which is a terrorist group
responding to vicious British
imperialism that killed innocent Arab
every resistance movement against
colonialism domination and oppression
aarth like conditions you have
nonviolent streams you have nonviolent
streams the first anied was nonviolent
the second one was primarily nonviolent
only with rocks and what did JFK said
when you make nonviolent Revolution
impossible you make violent revolution
inevitable you had to with the Jewish
her gone there's always been terrorist
expression the problem is the IDF which
comes out of jabotinsky which was tied
to the Jewish and terrorist history and
and this is a part of Jewish history
it's not all there's been the Einstein
and the Albert Magnus and other others
who call for very different things but
when I hear my brother Eugene say
they've only killed Hamas they killed
two Christian women in front of a church
a mother and a grandmother you mean
almost 8,000 children are being shielded
by Hamas do you really believe the world
is going to think that serious these
justifications are as weak as PRI Sweden
Kool-Aid when we see the massive
suffering of precious Palestinians who
are innocent so this notion that somehow
you can continue to late put forward
these lies though brother Eugene the
world is no longer convinced and you
know thisin the Jewish Community I've
got to leave the debate I'm sorry we run
out of time I've got to leave a debate
there it's a interesting debate uh
passions run high on both sides thank
you both very much for joining me Corel
I want to wish you uh ongoing success
with your uh campaign in the
presidential race The Economist both of
you Brothers both of you Brothers I pray
for your families and stay strong and
let's try to hold up A bloodstain Banner
of some serious morality and spiritual
in a moment of massive hatred and
tribalism Y I would the name of Amos in
the name of Isaiah and in the name of
Jesus I would certainly agree with that
but I was going to read you a quote from
The Economist today which said Cornell
West has the Charisma and energy of
James Brown if the Godfather of Soul had
also gone to graduate school and if that
isn't something you want to put on your
Tombstone one day Corner West you're mad
well that's not true James Brown is far
beyond me but I aspire to that kind of
movement and that
that kind of f my brother
absolutely it's great to see you and
thank you very much Eugene as well for
joining